[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur verließ
welt dieses jahr schaffen wir es
wirklich wir machen ein raclette video
wir nehmen uns glaube ich schon seit
einigen jahren vor genauso wie der
reporter ok könntest rausschneiden lebe
das sind drin und dieses jahr schaffen
wir es wirklich raclette aber hören was
ganz besonderes wir machen nämlich pizza
vom raclette das heißt ihr könnt
wirklich einiges super vorbereiten den
hefeteig tomatensoße den belag ich zeige
euch verschiedene tipps und tricks und
dann wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr wirklich
zu silvester raclette machen und dabei
eben diese pizza machen ja wir mussten
uns erst mal ein raclette grill wieder
ausleihen vom team denn wir haben ja gar
keinen mehr aber jetzt denke ich mir so
schade eigentlich ich
glaube ich behalten einfach ihr kriegt
mich mal nach hause wir können die
einfach hier übergriff ereignet machen
egal jetzt mache ich erstmal den
hefeteig den mache ich nämlich so mit
ganz wenig hefe der kommt dann in den
kühlschrank ihr könnt es also sozusagen
morgens schon alles vorbereiten und
mittags abends oder wann auch immer er
dann essen wollt könnt ihr alles einfach
nur noch raus holen und dann wirklich
schön raclette essen ich mache jetzt
einen hefeteig also den pizzateig für
den pizzateig nämlich einen viertel
würfel hefe 500 gramm warmes wasser
einen teelöffel zucker 900 gramm mehl 2
teelöffel salz etwas pfeffer und 90
gramm olivenöl und hier ist meine
fleißig gegeben
ja das ist eine figur von ella und das
bin ich als tierärzte ja gesagt dass
jemand auch tierärztin werden dabei bin
ich ja eigentlich gar keine politische
gedicht
samstag stehen bleiben
ich nehme jetzt zuerst einmal die hefe
die lese ich hier im wasser auf einfach
so ein spruch was damit rein
den zucker mit rein
da draußen steht mein papa der film
werben sogar
vom vorhaben nicht geerntet
der befindet hat noch himbeeren im
winter bei uns
und jetzt hier verrührt und dann kurz
vor etwa zehn minuten 15 minuten stehen
lassen diesen vorteil
es geht die fifa schon mal schön auch
dass auch immer ein ganz guter tipp denn
so seht ihr auf eure hilfe funktioniert
oder nicht manchmal kriege ich nämlich
kommentare die dann eben sagen menschen
ein hefeteig der ist nicht aufgegangen
es kann aber auch wirklich daran liegen
dass die hefe mal schlecht ist und so
könnt ihr einfach kontrollieren ob sie
eben funktioniert oder nicht also kurz
abdecken und einer viertelstunde stehen
lassen
so sieht es das man sieht schon ganz
deutlich
da tut sich etwas und jetzt kann ich
denn hier wird eilig verkneten das heißt
alle zutaten kommen hier in die
küchenmaschine ihr könnt aber natürlich
auch den teig mit der hand verkneten
die hefe mit rein das spüre ich jetzt
nicht schon aus
perfekt
abgehörtes moment darüber gesprochen es
tut mir leid
und dass dazu und dann sollen etwa fünf
bis sieben minuten in allen
geschmeidigen teig kneten
und forme den teig jetzt zu einer kugel
decke ihnen dann ab und schloss hinauf
gehen ich lasse jetzt bei raumtemperatur
aufgehen denn wir machen jetzt gleich
unser raclette in der zeit kann ich
nämlich die soße vorbereiten und alles
aber ihr könnt ihn jetzt wie gesagt auch
einfach in den kühlschrank stellen
abgedeckt und ihn da wirklich
stundenlang drin stehen lassen gerne
auch einen tag dann könnt ihr den super
vorbereitung ich zeige euch jetzt eben
mal kurz die zutaten für die tomatensoße
die mache ich jetzt auch selber dafür
nämlich 40 km olivenöl 2 zwiebeln 2
knoblauchzehen 40 gramm tomatenmark 800
gramm tomaten aus der dose und hier auch
die gewürze einen teelöffel oregano und
paprikapulver einen halben teelöffel
zucker einen teelöffel salz und einen
halben teelöffel pfeffer das olivenöl
gebe ich jetzt schon immer einen topf da
kann ich schon mal aufwärmen die zwiebel
und knoblauchzehen die werde ich fein
hacken normalerweise würde ich jetzt die
soße einfach auch hinter kern gutmachen
weil die ja auch diese funktion hatte
ich darin kochen kann und auch nicht
rühren muss aber für euch mache ich es
einfach jeden topf
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die zwiebel und
knoblauchzehen in öl anbraten
etwa drei bis vier minuten bis sie
glasig sind dann kommt direkt das
tomatenmark dazu die tomaten aus der
dose die gewürze und dann darf dieses
kochen also das ist echt nicht schwierig
und die mache ich echt gerne weil dieser
total witzig ist
[Musik]
sobald die soße kocht sich den deckel
auf stellen die hitze auf etwa 3
herunter und lass die soße der etwa 15
minuten einkochen und dann ist sie
fertig und ich kann mich jetzt schon um
den belag kümmern pizzabelag könnt ihr
natürlich wählen so wie ihr möchtet ich
mache es noch einen chicken barbecue
oder barbecue schicken dazu und zeigt
euch dafür mal eben was ich dafür
vorbereitet für das barbecue schicken
brauche ich barbecue sauce die selbst
gemacht und die habe ich echt vor über
einem halben jahr gemacht und hält
richtig lange
das solltet ihr mal ausprobieren ich
habe mich etwas butterschmalz und
hähnchenbrust die hähnchenbrust habe ich
jetzt bereits fein geschnitten wieso
geschnetzeltes ich habe jetzt hier auch
schon ein bisschen butter schmalz drin
und brathähnchen ganz scharf an
dafür muss ich natürlich die pfanne
nehmen es dann raus sobald ist durch ist
also wirklich schön durch franken bei
hähnchen geflügel generell immer darauf
achten immer nur durchgegart werden und
dann wird es gleich mariniert
ich mache das einfach in einzelnen
fraktionen so kühlt die panne nämlich
nicht herunter und es kocht nicht
sondern es geht wirklich die schwester
roben und das hähnchen ist rundherum
schön gebräunt
[Musik]
sobald es hinten angebrachten ist für
mich es wird mit der barbecue sauce und
verpasst dann einfach was es stehen uns
ziehen
im pool ist doch nur steht
das zusammenstehen und durch sie und
kann jetzt noch zutaten vorbereiten wie
salami oder bis in paprika schneiden
champignons schneiden und dann würde ich
sagen sehen wir uns gleich nach vorne am
tisch wenn wir dann unsere raclette
pizza vorbereitung
am tisch steht jetzt alles bereit jetzt
portion ich noch den teig vor denn die
raketen sind wirklich winzig also mache
ich so 20 gramm belchen und die kommen
hier in der schüssel mit bisschen
olivenöl zu kleben sie nicht aneinander
und dann können wir uns gleich an den
tisch setzen ich glaube die anderen sind
auch schon ganz hungrig
[Musik]
ja
also ich bin ganz ehrlich ich möchte
nicht neben volkan sätzen warum weil die
einfach kein schlechtes gewissen haben
möchte während ich möchte muss man den
veganer setzen beim retten heraklion zu
kommen wollten dann kommt er zu mir
hast du dich in den pilzen sitzen okay
an einer frist nach vordersitzen einer
muss der teig master sein
okay dann setze ich erklär ich ja mal
was vorbereitet das macht das nicht mehr
und wirke wohl kannst mir nicht
irgendwas regen dabei kann sagt nicht
ok also
der teig ist vorbereitet sehr mag denken
kannst du jetzt aus rollen was
wäre wenn es eine epidemie ausgebrochen
wäre
genau so oft fähnchen größte
wo ich mich gerade verarscht und vox die
gleiche hände etwas so hießen händen der
hat was war es nur in pizza teig
perfekt
danke das ja auch da ist wurde
nach ihm ist da noch so diese antworten
es war am rand eines ich sagen so noch
nie gemacht ich auch nicht dass wegen
dieser mega cool gibt es bei euch zu
hause auch ab jetzt zu silvester meisten
zugesetzt silvester einmal im jahr kommt
erklärt raus
geburtstag gibt es für euch auch
komplett habe ich bis jetzt einmal
wissen
ich möchte
verstehen jedoch was ich gelöscht mit
der prozession und teigtaschen oder so
ich mag mir gar nicht robert kaese der
stinker stinkt das ganze haus haben wir
david lesern ein wachturm firma das
trifft jetzt eben die pfännchen rein und
dann direkt tomatensoße drauf
und dann hier stehen verteilen und teig
und soße ist alles wieder andere und
dann können das leben ich glaube ich
nehme
alles tun
nicht
so schön ja genau in öl eingelegt
hla magst du auf
mir jetzt erstmal so gut macht sie hier
eine kleine pizza obwohl hier
[Musik]
das neue jahr ist irgendwas corviglia
ich wollte eigentlich seit 2008
abnehmen und das kann zu hier
hast du dir was vorgenommen für 222
etwas ändern
und das bild etwas vorgenommen für 2020
also was sie beachten muss beim raclette
pizza zubereiten ist dass der teig ist
extrem dünn sein muss denn die hitze die
kommt ja von oben das ist ähnlich wie so
ein pizzaofen dass die hitze von unten
kommt und wenn der pizzateig süchtig ist
dann ist nämlich durch und der belag
verwendet also pizzateig deswegen
gemacht ganz dünn machen und dann
aber kam dieser allgemein richtig cool
funktionstüchtig trägt man regen langsam
an kopf zusammen irgendwie ja
ich habe nette frau bereitet alles vor
die männer essen da man in form eines
schicken dann reden wenn man bei herten
ist kann es sei ja ganz schlimm madonna
zone machen naja ich kann so etwas drauf
und hab gemerkt wir haben keines zu
typischen so aufgefallen war aus leider
wird bereitet
[Musik]
wohl kann wenn man sich die türen zur
hilfe gekommen das schweigen der lämmer
wird
hab jetzt mit veganer die marksteine
mediums
wir haben sie jetzt aus dem feldchen
raus nach oben hin damit der boden
praktisch noch ein bisschen geröstet
wird jetzt immer praktisch die zweite
schon belegt okay findet ihr sowohl als
ich finde das ganz
genau
bestimmt bürgern mehr sprechen weniger
ist hast du den alltag wenn zwei
semester soll ich es gut man ist
automatisch langsam richtig und es heißt
sich das sättigungsgefühl setzt früher
ein war dies weniger aber recht
wenig
dass der markt nicht erreichen
[Musik]
jetzt auch gesellschaften nicht richtig
cool man redet viel man kann auch ein
bisschen an der hafenbrücke und
herzen fehlender
alternativen zum nummer und steht nicht
so direkt bestimmt die magpies ehrlich
sagen auch ein bisschen
über das
freunde und feinde hört doch natürlich
aber daheim
warum
ist das so nach hinten ließen zloty ich
habe übrigens noch viel trägt also ich
glaube dass die trinkmenge für uns auf
jeden fall ausreicht um auch für viele
weitere und auch den job steht alles
oder der kostenlosen app
nachmachen schön sind weste haben mit
eurem freund
in diesem jahr das letzte video wir
sehen uns den nächsten jahren vielleicht
kommt noch ein jahres mit mac
[Musik]